Here's our final answer. Excellent work if you figured that one out. We know
that a square or an exponent of two means that we write this out twice. We're
multiplying this binomial by itself. Next we want to distribute 3 root 3 to our
second binomial. So for the first term we'll have 3 root three times 3 root 3.
For the second term we'll have 3 root 3 times 5. Once we've distributed that 3,
3 now we want to distribute this positive 5, well that positive 5 times 3, 3 or
the 3rd term and positive 5 times positive 5 for a 4th term, we multiply these
two terms together to get 9 times 3, when were at the square root of any number
times itself is just that number For these two terms, we'll 15 root 3, and 15
root 3, and on the end we have a positive 25. We can combine these terms
together, since they both have a radical of square root of 3. So we have 30
square roots of 3, 9 times 3 is 27, and I move this 25 over here, so I can add
my like terms together to get the final result. Great thinking if you got here.